hey everyone welcome to the warlord
podcast i'm james marshall and this
episode is brought to you by puresport
cbd
and straight face and straight faces a
new partner have come on board who sell
five blade razors delivered to your door
at the cost of a three blade razor from
the supermarket
it's an awesome setup if you love your
clean shave and you've run out of razors
make sure you go give these guys a try
you can do so by heading over to
straight face dot co dot nz
use offer code lads put that in the
promo code and you'll get a whopping 50
off your first order definitely worth a
try make sure you do that
and also the merch is going to drop soon
so make sure you go over and check that
out
support this merch so we can help grow
this podcast all the profits will go
back into this podcast so i can deliver
you guys a better product if you're
enjoying the podcast please support the
podcast by getting yourself some merch
the merch is going to drop on the 30th
of
april remember that date and get ready
to wear some awesome
woodland gear but anyway roll the intro
[Applause]
[Music]
what a lad and what a lad i have for you
guys today
an absolute superstar of both codes he
first started in the nrl for the cowboys
before heading to super rugby with the
western force and the sun wolves
where he dominated for both those teams
recently
been carving up over in japan including
some world-class performances for the
japan national side at the last world
cup
it is one of the great lads will tupole
welcome thanks for having me brother hey
thanks for coming on and look at your
picture you
you look like you've just gone and
bought a brand new computer
first guy to ever go buy a new computer
to come on the podcast
that is a massive shout out 100 i did
actually
when he told me to jump on and he said
need a laptop and i was like
i actually don't have a laptop mate so i
had to ask the wife
yesterday is it okay if i could spend a
bit on myself
you've got way too much money over there
right just oh here he is the cheapest
one they had there i said
i just want the cheapest one that works
for a podcast oh
that picture looks unreal that's one of
the most expensive ones yet oh here he
is
what's been going on nothing much bro um
we're on the break now we
played our last game against mitzi yeah
it was a tough one
it looked looked all too familiar for
the mighty red sparks
it's like deja vu really it's like oh
i've been here before
you know oh no yeah
what uh i don't know i thought we had
the game and oh that's like every game
we play really at the cola
you think you have it and last five
minutes
yeah the other team has it and then
do you get to the point in the games
where like uh even though you're up with
like 10 to go you're like uh
we're probably gonna lose this oh i'm
panicking all right because i'm like oh
please don't
be a repeat like i think we're winning
by a try or three points and i was like
oh
you know looking at the time hoping that
time just fast-forwards itself a
but you know i've been at coldwell four
or five years now and i just
yeah i feel the same pretty much every
game especially when we're
when we're on top we miss you bro that's
what that's what we needed we needed we
needed a finisher
yes and i was not there
yeah i remember every time you you
because you you were out
quite a bit last year or the end of the
year before with a few injuries and
international
commitments but man every time you came
back
wow we the team was just they got a buzz
out of it because it was
having like a legend playing with the
boys
and i'm surprised i'm still playing to
be honest like getting gigs
especially with my energies left right
so today this shield was man it was
terrible
did my left in my right did my unquad
did my peck
like what's your left and right what's
that one so i did my left hammy
oh i hear me came back after three four
weeks did my right hand me
first came back um
came back did a bit of kicking um
did a a strain straightened my
quad and then you know much i was like
oh my how come you're not kicking i was
like no no
just go look after my quad
yeah i'm questioning myself mate how do
i well what do i do do i think about
plan b
or do i just keep grinding keep grinding
right
oh keep going are the training still
playing up because man
some of those trainings that we had over
there when i was there were just playing
i think it got worse bro to be honest
better um
yeah like we this year is the first time
we had four days
early wednesday off yeah yeah so
it's gotten worse but i was like we
would sometimes we do 10k days
eight k's yeah wonder your hammies are
going
terrible it's terrible honestly like and
then what tuesday
so leading on to the game tuesday is a
full contact day
like 15 on 15. thursday's the same
friday captain's run
everyone's feels like they already
played two games in that week before the
main game on saturday
does that sound familiar or is that a
bit different from when you were here
sounds all too familiar
oh you and benny will be sapping away at
the back though you and ben lucas
yeah we just complain hey sometime i'll
just think about to myself like mate
i've got to stop complaining i wake up
every morning on the train
complaining about something it's not
good eh
oh you might be ready for something else
but anyway
we've got we've got such a journey to
get through because man your career
i went through it last night and your
career is honestly like one of the
greats
so i'm looking forward to getting
through this so let me have a lot of
survival
you've done it all you've done it all
who would have thought but anyway let's
let's let's start at the start because i
know you're a japanese
international but i know you weren't
born there so take our listeners back to
what it was like for you growing up um
well i was born in auckland auckland new
zealand my old man moved to
oz for a bad opportunity obviously got a
job there and
obviously rang old lady and told her
like you know maybe it's time to move
on to australia and see you know what
the opportunities like there for us i'm
i've been quite
young really i think one around one
years old so pretty much
yeah trying to hold on to that new
zealand partner still got it everyone's
like what are you doing
oh um yeah damn i wish you didn't ask me
that because i was telling you i know
yeah i'm gonna cheat kiwi bro
but yeah anyways moved over when i was
one
uh didn't play footy tours like tennis
really what were you doing
trying to avoid it really i just saw
like i loved watching it but then
just i was playing a bit of cricket robe
um
sing all around us and
um yeah he played a bit of cricket when
i was young but um yeah got into footy
when i was 10 years old
then yeah took him from there bro you
must have been the natural gun
from it at 10 years old that's true
we had no shoes bare feet humble days
oh yeah yeah did you guys say that back
to back in new zealand
not at 10 though was it oh there's like
five but 10 you're starting to get
semi-pro
you probably you were probably
contracted at 10.
well that's the one who's going up there
in australia is still battling
what's it called yeah i don't know why
my family
or my parents put me here at 10a my mum
said that i didn't really like the
contact side of it i loved watching it
but i just didn't see myself
jumping on someone in yeah
i just started growing when i was 17 bro
like when i was 17 i started yeah
going to bed but you were good before
then i because i remember your
queensland under 16 side
that was a stacked stack team
yeah i wouldn't say that was good i was
i was lucky to be honest um
who was it yeah we had a really well all
those guys all wallaby players are we
had um
joe to maine ben
um james slipper i mean there's so many
like
um aiden tour true where were you
playing
what position i was the water boy oh
yeah if they if they had no one i was
like yeah
look i brought my boots on tour so now i
was playing um a bit of center
wing bro um either starting or number 23
yeah
oh yeah how did you make the why'd you
make the transition to league how did
that come about
um we had andrew mccallis i'm not sure
if you know him he's uh
he was a broncos hooker for a while now
oh yeah yeah um he he came to my school
so
you move over for the come uh from the
countries and uh
they needed him to be at a school in
brisbane so
which they'd like they're located him at
prince state high which was the school
that i went to
yeah um then he just spoke to me one
time because um he was on broncos and
going to school at the same time and he
was asking me mate do you have you ever
seen yourself playing league and i was
like
what was that so he told me mate do you
want to come down to training or like
you know if
if we can have someone ring you up and
explain to you you know what they're
what the bronx about so yeah start from
there then my man goes yeah mate you can
do anything
now i was like i knew nothing about me i
started league at 16. i didn't know they
had markers i was the third mark every
time
getting penalized i was getting
penalized uh
yeah it's quite funny really you live
and you learn eh
well you you must have learned pretty
quick because you were in the broncos
toyota cap squad pretty quick eh
yeah i was one of the honestly i was one
of the lucky ones because um
back when when the 20s came we had heaps
of um older boys you know like
experienced boys but i think
um the coach and the staff wanted to use
up the younger boys
i think they must have saw you know that
these guys can grow and learn a bit
and um yeah we stacked ourselves with um
like we splitted like half experienced
guys and half young fellas yeah
and i was lucky enough to get a chance
to play in that team yeah i didn't think
i was going to make it to be honest
because
it was my first time learning league
first time getting flogged
was terrible at fitness
didn't mind contact i think that's what
they liked about it
about myself and then yeah it went for
bed and
obviously when they named the squad and
the team to play yeah i was
yeah it's pretty pretty happy and pretty
privileged to be
yeah to be able to play starting center
on one side yeah
and this you had your growth spurt by
then a so you were you're a big guy yeah
i think
i started growing then um learned yeah
yes at 17 18 i started growing a bit
yeah
a lot of my mates over the years while i
may you were short before so yeah i
wasn't that big
so who else was who else was in that um
broncos site
ah frank josh hoffman jared bill
gerald yao yi um andrew mccallive
um alex glenn yeah what uh
uh frank uh josh mcguire
ben hunt um you you may know him um
jared kahu do you know joe ko yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he was out here yeah he wasn't he was at
half um five eight at the time man
killed it for us i don't know why he
left to be honest yeah um
yeah we had a pretty stacked teammate
like like we we all talk about
the old boys like mate we didn't even
know that we'll go anywhere because
um during that con wheel the underdogs
so like oh yeah don't know why bronx put
in
a young team don't you know are they
gonna ever stand a chance against the
sydney team because mate these sydney
teams have like stuck
tony williams like big boys and these
guys are 20 we're all like
just turn 18 you know true yeah so how
did you go
how'd that go oh yeah oh
oh no oh you're so humble no
you don't have to be humble on this
honestly i was lucky enough to
to have an okay season that yeah no
in your language that means you
absolutely ripped it up no
no i had an okay season honestly i was
lucky enough to play under a good coach
wayne bennett no i'm not waiting better
oh frank
he scares me hey my first year there
i remember having to talk to him sorry
that they needed um some young fellas to
come and um
is this when you when you're in the um
toyota cap side you got
into training yeah i'm caught into the
preseason game and they needed some
young guys to obviously
see if they can fill out some spots
throughout the season
a good opportunity to play on the wing
to be honest
because i was young i just saw it like
oh crap i get to play with um
you know like darren lock yeah pj
martia's our
[Music]
all these big names that you know they
used to watch when you're young and i
just saw it as
like um how do you say it
look i didn't really take it serious
with the opportunity i was getting and
then later on down the track i got told
yeah mate this is
they're actually giving you a shot to
see um they needed a winger
to start off the season and like i
didn't get that drift i just got it not
cool i get to
play again with these big dogs and
yeah and then i remember that training
wayne goes how good are you on the
highball and i was like oh i'm okay i
guess mate it's either yes or no
and i was like oh yes sir i'm good he
said you go to the field
down like he comes out kicks a few balls
over shot the first one he goes
and i can see him gone no no you know i
started catching him
and he was like yeah man i'll go easier
now i'll just i won't talk i'll just
whack it but even though even the normal
kicks were just like holy hecka
yeah but yeah that's my experience i'm
not scared after when he said mate
yes or no i was like yes but with a high
pitched voice like yeah
so how old are you here um i think i was
just 18.
all
yes i finished high school the following
year i was turning 18 in july and i
think that was the preset one of the
pre-season games
yeah i got lucky yeah when i look back
now i was like i wish i kinda took that
opportunity
a little serious you know when you when
you're a young kid are you just kind of
like
honestly when i was passing i think yeah
it was like a kick it was a
fifth last and i and there was no hook
and i was there and lockers yeah mate
just passed it to me and i was like
i'm gonna shot the ball because he was
talking to me like holy he's he's asking
me to pass through the ball so you know
passing the ball and you know yeah i'll
chase everything
yeah how did you get called into the
cowboys because you obviously didn't
play in a rail game for the broncos
first game was for the cowboys yeah so
the second year at the bronx uh
so i think you know the thing is like
you pick five young guys to go in the
top 25 to fill up the top 25.
the top squad so yeah why at that stage
that following year i was playing back
row
center um but then i've got opportunity
one one of my mate he was a coach at the
bronx
i spoke to um neil henry down at um the
cows and they needed to center back row
so obviously i fitted in and he was like
may go
up there and do your thing and then when
you ever want to come back come back
so i end up staying there two years
uh got my first gig there um in 2010
yeah it was on real way it was like i i
kind of went deaf
just you know i've got to contract the
cows just
see how it goes you know not like oh
yeah i want to play
what's it called nrl and stuff but yeah
i was lucky enough i think the fourth
round in 2010 they
we made a few changes me and my mate um
ray thompson
debuted for uh against the titans
and yeah got told off from jt that first
game
yeah and like did you what did he say
because i still love you jay
that was one of my favorite parts about
playing at coke was hearing your jt
stories every day you're the one who
mocks me now i don't even know
about it you used to tell me a cool jt
story
every day i used to love it so give me
your first one here we go on day before
anyways
played um titans and do you know
milocello though
what um
he's a big boy i'm a stick right so he
runs a good short ball
obviously i was the guy in front uh you
know i went to connor
i should try to tackle bella you know
it's like a like a little hug and then
kind of
put this big fin in the middle of my
chest obviously offended they scored and
jt goes mate
welcome to nrl this is yeah anyway
because mate
you've got to get in there next time
with someone so and i was like
there's my they put you you know he was
telling me don't put your head down now
mate
you know next job next job no no yeah
sweet
and i felt so small when he goes mate
welcome there nrl
welcome to the big boy stuff
yeah every single step yeah i had to
huddle up
[Laughter]
but you obviously played well enough to
keep your spot yeah honestly i was lucky
enough to play
amongst those fellas when i look back
now you know we had a really good
team but obviously didn't have a good
season
but uh yeah your team was stacked but
there's one one date that i remember
everyone remembers where they were that
day the 24th of july
2010 golden point
cowboys versus newcastle yeah
it's the ball throws it to willie tonga
he squares up the last defender
gives it to tupa on the 40. what do you
do
talk me through it i'll i'll talk you
through it
yeah when i've got the ball
as a winger everyone expects a wing to
do something right i wasn't
to be honest i wasn't really those
wingers who can freaking create
magic so anyways lucky enough um who was
the
the last you saw you guys playing
newcastle
yeah obviously lucky he slipped off my
leg and then
to be honest he wasn't playing like i
remember getting introduced mate did you
plan that did you know that you're going
to come back in and back out said no i
didn't know
it was kind of like just try to do
something you know obviously got him
points
um i was lucky enough giddy let go of my
leg and then you know
try to pretend i could step and then you
know
in and out and yeah lucky enough to get
that choice
but it's a flick yeah it wasn't planned
you know it was like oh
how'd i do i was shocked too whenever
you scored on that before
how do i get here just blacked out
i just went into god mode for about 10
seconds it was unbelievable
and with the celebrations after that you
must have earned the team's respect you
must have felt pretty good after that
because obviously
you just won the game for the boys yeah
you know
obviously um lucky i did score that try
because there's a i think there's a
a few times that i dropped the high ball
i think i jammed i should have
because i was getting to water it made
fruit try defending that guy one on one
and
i think i let him in twice not let him
once but it was pretty crucial that
if he didn't get a try we would have
still you know be comfortable ahead yeah
but anyways
scored a try i just remember looking up
and everyone was like come on mate make
that tackle
in my head i was like how about like try
to stop that ball coming out here
but you know lucky enough honestly it's
something that i'll remember
um i i still get buzzy because honestly
when i when i look and i was like man
how did jimmy get there
yeah was that your favorite try of your
career
yeah it's probably the only tribe scored
in my career to be honest
did jt shout you after that he must what
did he say
i don't know i just remember the guy
goes mate that's
that's how you score that's how you play
now we had a good crew man i think we
had a good culture there you know it's
um
you know getting high fives from these
guys like man i'm in the club now y'all
no but yeah getting getting comments
like that from the big dogs you know
it's
it means a lot as a young guy trying to
trying to create a career in their
morale i know you were dead real young
too away so had you had a
child at this age did you boy at this
age a bad memory
um i hadn't no i haven't i had my first
one when i was 21.
you're only 21. i was i was married
young yeah
i was married at uh
i think 19 10 20 yeah did you
yeah you just knew love at first sight
yeah i know i need i knew jazzy was the
one i just uh
yeah happiness just
needs to lock it in just in case she um
changes their mind
now how long how long have you been
together
um a year and a half true it's pretty
sure today
oh no i might as well say the story so
anyways i was moving
moving from brizzy to townsville and
obviously um i told jazz like you know
oh do you want to get married down the
track and she's like oh why not now and
i was like oh
this is yeah i just signed a contract
i'm not sure if it's stable or not but
yeah
um then you know obviously i wanted to
ask your dad so i was like god do you
mind if fight
because why would you want to ask me now
so i just thought it's a
it's a good thing to do even though i
didn't want to go home and say
hey look is it okay um
[ __ ] marry your daughter anyways yeah
that's what happened and he goes look i
didn't want her to go over
be the boyfriend girlfriend and then
have to give up her work that she had
just to come up there for my work you
know so that's the process because if
you do love her
um then yeah you have to so i went and
asked him and
man i sounded like a girl wise the high
pitched voice came out and i was like
and then he gets made you on water and i
was like yeah is it a camera a glass of
water please yeah
i just told him um yeah i was quite
young it's just
i think jazz didn't want to move without
committing to something commitment yeah
yeah and i wanted to commit but it was a
lot it was
quite almighty what kind of 19 year old
thanks here man i'm going to get married
i said for myself but yeah so obviously
we got engaged
and it wasn't romantic it was just like
would you marry me and joe's like are
you asking me or
oh yeah i'm marching here she's like
yeah of course i was oh cool
that was that was my little romantic
moment
anyways yeah she came over after six
months i was there
lost a lot of weight training was
freaking tough
um yeah that's how it happened got
married in townsville
and yeah history took over
yeah that's it are you now he's still
together still happily married
two kids third on the way yeah what a
dream couple
i hope this one listens against the
mother too oh
they got my ears
[Laughter]
so you obviously played two years at the
cowboys
yep two very good years so then what was
what was the reason behind the move to
the force everyone a lot of my mates
asked me that and it was pretty awkward
um
how'd it happen i i played um every time
we had a blind week or if we didn't make
the nrl team
we'll go back to our theater club team
right so
the guide um siebel he was the the bronx
coach
yeah and he was my company yes and he
was uh
he was a melbourne for a bit and manly
um
so he spoke to someone that he knew from
western force and they said they're
pretty keen on a center
he tells me about it and i just went
look i played union before so that's
something that i grew up on
yeah so it wouldn't hurt so i spoke to
my old man and he goes look it's up to
you
but i was going through a lot of
injuries at the cows and i i thought
that was my life
my excuse to kind of leave you i mean
like
yeah so i thought that was the answer so
i was like yeah i'll take this job
i needed something different i needed to
travel you know said i was going to
start there so
i think that's what caught me yeah and
it must have been a mess of coin it was
massive and because
i was still talking to the cows and they
said um can you think about it you know
because we
obviously we want to keep you on and i
wasn't really thinking i was thinking
about love god i need to clear my head
space maybe moving
is the right thing to do yeah so
yeah that's how it got dead and
obviously these these coaches are from
brisbane so it's a small world they've
said that who they knew and i knew them
and
that's how i got there yeah through the
coachella's uh
my feeding team and he knew maybe then
that yeah that's how i
got over to the force did you ever miss
rugby when you're playing league or not
really
nah i i didn't watch any rugby to be
honest it was just league
all the way yeah when you were young you
loved union and then when you
started switching to leg you just fully
immersed into league
yeah i just thought look if i'm going to
move i might as well give it a good
crack you know
yeah and um i've got enough um mole man
i always tell you you've got nothing to
lose if you've got a leak if you don't
like it and obviously
you can come back and um start from
scratch but yeah i was lucky enough that
when i made the move it kind of worked
out you mean so i was one of those
players who were lucky enough to get
that opportunity to
get a crack at it in the road and
obviously get a crack of super
i'm not even lucky to even stay on footy
to be honest yeah so
it's all about opportunity to be honest
and and what coaches love you and what
coaches don't
so yeah oh it's a massive part of it a
context and who likes you
and yeah who's going to give you places
it's crazy yeah
yeah great advice for anyone listening
is don't burn bridges with coaches they
just
keep them all happy because you never
know it's such a small world
everyone knows everyone guys move and
you think you might not see that coach
again but man
five years down the track he's probably
going to be a coach again that's the
thing
i think that's um as players we don't we
don't get that you know we
we kind of get caught in the moment like
oh i look uh i'll just leave it's
business got to go but then like
when you build a good relationship with
a coach or one of the staffs then they
don't
like you know down track you need a job
they you know they can go mate he's he
was a good kid when i
when he was in the same team that i was
and you know and i think that's what i
was
lucky enough to to have good coaches and
build all you know
a good relationship with them and to be
able to hold a contract wherever
i was going to go you know you're a good
kid
so talk to me about your move to the
force what was it like when you first
went over then
having to adapt to union again oh my
scary hey um
my uh went to the force with
hardly any money um they put us up what
did you do with your league many
oh my long story we'll keep it short but
yeah
anyways um i wonder
laptops
oh no anyways long story
short went to the force with um whatever
savings we had
we got told we got to be um at a hotel
for two weeks until
they find us a place right so it wasn't
really a solid um
oh the contract was solid but how they
organized it wasn't really
professional if you think about it yeah
so they put us at a hotel two weeks and
our two weeks up so
we had nowhere to go like obviously they
couldn't find us the house
by two weeks and it was just like all
over the shop so we were lucky enough to
to find another place so we moved out of
this hotel right and then we caught
everyone everyone said they're booked
as soon as we moved out i'll show you
jazz you know what we might as well just
well yummy was like not even one yet
we're like
we're gonna sleep in a car tonight
because we can't find you anyways a
hotel
bring us up safe someone cancelled and
we we stayed in there for like
maybe another week and then oh we went
and stayed you know peck however
yeah yeah yeah yeah stayed with him we
were telling us
about my story about having them home
and then you know they took us in for
a week or two oh that's true and yeah
that's how my experience at uh before
starting was just
yes yeah so when did when did you find a
place
hey everyone that supports the force
going on watching his mate will's
talking rubbish
and uh uh i think
now i'll say a month and a bit
oh real hell yeah so we stayed at peck
felt so from you know
creeping up his style at home and it was
all there for a week or two
found a place expensive but you know we
had to deal with it
no i didn't have them on yesterday when
the lady told me to rent and i was like
oh have you ever not seen my contract or
is it just uh
oh sorry so if you could sign here and
here i'm like oh no but
have you seen my contract yet before i
sign
yeah we got a house cost what 7 50
a week and onsen upstairs downstairs so
it was me my little family really needed
the rooms downstairs
and had upstairs with its own lounge
room
and then when i said yeah so the dogs
were 250 each oh
headaches and you know that's when i
started counting all my coins like oh
okay
i got milk got petrol
um yeah that's how it started which we
just started there yeah anyways
got the opportunity to start off injured
again
the hammies went richard graham was the
coach at that time
i remember him stressing his mate look
we need you right because um
you have to be right by i think it was
like two weeks uh in two weeks
where they're gonna pick the you know
the squad he was made we need you right
so
play came back and play one of the trial
games and then at training did miami
been lucky yeah man like my whole career
just
just up and down with injuries eh and um
yeah good opportunity of round four
pretty much similar to league
against the tars um i think they weren't
really winning any game but
i'm not saying that i came back at one
i've said the boys turned up
on my debut because you were there
though did they all know you from league
and did they
all think oh were you the big dog no i
wasn't a big dog but
i don't know you know obviously the
boy's like oh here who's this lead guy
he comes here and
tries to take the center spot and so on
so oh that's the vibe i felt when i came
you know
doesn't even know how to spin the ball
still passing like the league anyways
did you say them you try
[Laughter]
on the group what set
um yeah so it's like i s when i started
the force it started off like that you
know i think the vibe was like oh this
guy's coming from league and obviously
this coach likes him
what's he about and all that and that's
how i started uh obviously
lucky i defended okay against the tars
and then like you know got a little bit
of respect i remember peacock being a
cat uh
oh no sharpie was a character poker
gazette against
uh one of our drills a league like it
was like 7v7
and like in his group he goes well i
need you to
tell us what we should do as a defense
team and i was like holy heck
i'm still guessing my shots and stuff
but yeah anyways
everyone just cut legs all day now
so yeah i remember him telling me and i
was like freaking stalking me and
telling me to do this
you know obviously lead the boys um and
that's another team we had a stack team
too
and still couldn't you know perform well
on the game days yeah any highlights of
your time at the force
highlights maybe debuting against
guitars and obviously
um making a crucial
read and then obviously they knocked it
on here try a lot and you know
yes and i remember getting tired off
like because you know when someone
knocks on you make good read knocks on
you know you drop on the ball bait oh
you know i think i stood up and like did
the
did you see that did you did you guys
see that but just stop the try
[Laughter]
yeah i remember doing the video guys
mate look next time like uh
drop on the ball we know you did a hit
you know next job
right now sorry guys
my highlight is more like um being
around the lads you mean like um
like obviously the same thing like
sharpie was there
josh and matthew pick how like all these
wallaby guys you're like freak i used to
watch these guys
i'm actually in the same team and my
highlights will be like uh ketchup hey
off the field hey end of seasons or
oh just during the week you know
everyone just complained about life and
what the club's not doing and yeah i
think that's i didn't really have any
holiday i missed the beaches there the
hollow side of the beach i don't know
how to swim but yeah
i just like to take my surfboard and
pretend i'm out of surf
so what brought upon the move to japan
heading over to hino you're
at the force for two years headed to
hino what what was all that about um
i suffered a nerve problem did my
shoulder at
one of our club games and then i snapped
a nerve
um a force didn't want to take me on the
following year because i still have one
yeah they didn't want to take me on it
so it's pretty risky to have
a player like me not knowing if he can
play or not so
true we went back to oz got in contact
with a couple of league guys
on league teams and they knew that i was
coming back and um
like again i was lucky enough to to have
good relationship and they're referring
to these teams and
uh cooper was retiring at the dragons
one of the one of the legends of the
game
and they needed a center so obviously i
yeah obviously i got lucky to to get
like oh i had
an interest from the dragons judges
didn't want to go to sydney today
oh i remember getting a phone call
and i really wanted to go and then he
was ringing me up to find out my answer
and jazz goes no tell him no
you know me i'm the shyest guy ever i
don't know how to so here i am going to
look um
there's a family um problem that's just
come up uh
yeah yeah so i think say all these
things and i said i don't think it it's
the right time for us to move
so yeah it's gonna i actually got that i
was that close to go back to league and
they knew i had uh the nerve problem
they said look can we just
bring you over and see our specialists
and you know even do your rehab here and
stuff
yeah obviously then got to go to penrith
with
griffo he was the coach of the bronx but
he went took the head coach or assistant
coach at
uh penrith and he was asking me may i
look happy to have you
better we had to do it the right way i
had to you know start from scratch
because obviously i was over playing
union yeah
then uh the japan could go i was gonna
quit footing so that time
already when uh if if i'm not gonna play
league
i might as well just quit
and then uh i bumped into a good mate of
mine um
humic minimum and he referred me to his
agent
and i spoke to him and he said don't
quit man how about can i make a few
phone calls obviously he
um knows the market in japan so
yeah gave me an offer from hino and said
look would you go then jazzy didn't want
to go to japan and obviously
it was like if i'm not going to do
league and i'm not going to do that what
do i do so we were talking to the reds
at the time that carmichael took all the
budget
so um so you know it's either go there'd
be water boy for a year or two and
hopefully get a shot but yeah so we took
the hino job
took on that and they knew about my
shoulder they were happy
so when i went they did preseason i
didn't do anything bro so it was kind of
like
just let me heal and it got close to the
game and i started training and yeah
obviously
uh um did a test when i broke back to
brisbane and
the nerves started kicking in so yeah
that's how i got in japan really so
everything was a lot more
opportunity reason it was like i got
lucky
i was one of those lucky ones if you
have to say i'm one of those lucky
players who
i mean like the opportunity was gone but
then there's another door open you mean
another one
you're too you're too good not to have
opportunities it sounds like you had
about five different opportunities
there but what was the deciding factor
to take the japan one
you said jazz didn't want to go there
yeah it was hard uh
i don't know um thought of my little one
yeah i was like look we'll go there for
a year if i don't like it and i can
obviously because i had the
opportunities with some contracts in
australia can come back and
knock on their door and hopefully you
know they answer but um
we took the year on just like you know
let's go there for a year if we don't
like it then
you know we've tried it you know what an
experience to to have you know to be
able to go there and play in japan and
um do something different we loved it
after a year that the club asks we are
they were quite happy after six seven
months like i made like
um would you be willing to stay one more
year
so look i'm not i don't feel like going
back
now so yeah stayed at um for another
year
um yes i've been here for almost seven
years now all together
so was the japan international um scene
ever
ever on the mind that's yeah it's funny
everyone asked me that question that
honestly like uh super was never
in mind because when i left super i
promised myself i was gonna go somewhere
i'm gonna put my you know
all my heart and work into one team you
know did the second year of hino and
then super popped up you know um
first year of um sunnies came there
apparently
i wasn't allowed to get looking because
what the team
my company said no this is what i heard
look at my
my boss said no and we weren't div too
so they were looking at guys and did one
comps yeah um went to cola
uh cola put me into the super without
oxford yeah anyways long story short
was lucky enough to get another
opportunity at on sonny's
um yeah but like playing for japan and
playing for sunny was never in my um
like one of my goals there it was just
it's obviously like because i had a
young family it was just like just to
maintain a contract
and they have something to pay the bills
and put food on the table
you mentioned your move from kino to
coke what was
what was the reason behind that one
gotta be careful this one but yeah
um so i suffered a um
patellar problem on my my right knee so
i've never had it before
um and how many injuries have you had
yeah so i picked up this one and look at
that artificial grass
and it was one run like when i say one
run at that club it was like
we start off with fitness we and it was
like a long training block
then we finished with our two hour three
hour session and then we finished with a
15-minute
fitness at the end and it was just like
you know running
it's like pretty much running on
concrete and i picked up this injury i
went
uh i checked it here and they said
that's normal went back home and they
said i've got this big
blood clot behind my kneecap and they
said mate if you keep playing on there
you probably have to retire
um he knows found out about it on my
second year because obviously
they tried to rest me for four weeks but
it wasn't getting better like every time
i came back and i stepped off that it
just kept blowing up
yeah and they're trying to say i had
this injury you know when you when you
do a report when you come here you've
got to say all these injuries yeah yeah
never had to be telling my life well i
dropped every time when i played league
you know the wingers have a job never
had any problem with that but
when i came here they said i must have
had that earlier and didn't say anything
about it
yeah so they they wanted to keep me but
they said they didn't want to be
responsible
for if i was to retire in a couple years
yeah so they said look if you do want to
move on but they left me only two weeks
to look for a team so it's kind of like
if i couldn't find a team that i had to
stay at um you know yeah and lucky
tim bateman finished up at cola
everyone's already everyone's already
signed players and they needed the
center obviously
like i said opportunity i was lucky
enough to get the
the phone call and so we came and told
you know look we're moving to call and
call
like hey you found the club so obviously
he know right
is this true when over there yeah that's
how my um
yeah that's how i got to kohler and
still here so you're two years a
cowboys two years at force two years at
eno and now
about ten years yeah yeah just can't we
one of the break we wanted to break the
the two-year thing throughout with farm
at hino because it was like two years
there two years there
i should have stayed more at cows
shouldn't stay more thing but then you
know i like
got tahini wanted to break it and
obviously
had to move on and we did two years here
we were thinking about
like you know a movement but which i
just went look i've never broken the
two-year
drought so i need to you know at least
sign one more year
just to go yes i've just done two two
three you know i mean
so you got that and you know now it's
kind of like oh
still here same
same results now
but what about um your sun walls how was
how was it going into there because
obviously it was a new side
results weren't that great initially
yeah
all right to be honest i enjoyed footy
like looking at my career like
i know i've never been under a new
zealand coach right so
my old man talks about the new zealand
footy and how they enjoy and how they
see
footy and how australia don't you know
do the same so obviously
got my gig at the sunnies uh philotel
was the head coach
been hearing yeah they were the the zeal
coach but being on them and them
explained footy i just like
freak this is i'm like getting old and
i'm hearing this stuff now
you know um but like best culture
obviously the you know the results
wasn't we didn't get the results
when we played but best bunch of players
uh best group of guys coaches i learned
a lot yeah i
think that's the only time i enjoyed
footy you know we had a game plan but
when you have the ball if you see
something play it
if it doesn't work obviously you know
what you shouldn't have done
and i've never been under a coach who
said that you know obviously playing a
super in
force was like this is what you can do
this is what you can't do
yeah yeah you shouldn't kick you know
the kick goes like cool you shouldn't
pass
you just pass pops because obviously
your passing range is no good you know
but when you come here obviously this is
probably new zealand you know you guys
just have fun hey just
use the skills that you guys have and i
don't know
yeah lots of words really so then what
about japan because
who who was it jamie joe was the first
was he the one who picked you up in
japan
yeah my gig yeah i don't know how i'll
go to japan to be honest because i
already booked a holiday to go back and
then i got a
an email plus a course saying um did you
know
that you're eligible and i was like oh
legible for
like oh do you know legible for japan
and i was like oh am i now like oh do
you want to play for japan and i was
like
i i don't know like if if there's
opportunity yeah
you know i'll have a look they said
we've got a camp in two weeks um
jamie will like for you to come in yeah
that's that's how it got in bro it was
just like
over yeah just you know i didn't know
that i was it doesn't mean it was never
my goal to
to stay here long and to play for japan
it was just lucky if the opportunity was
there and then
yeah i took it because it must be weird
because you you
your japanese is pretty average probably
yeah or is it still
[Laughter]
no that's pretty average
so what was it like going into like a
full-on japanese national site
no it's all right because um sunnis are
the same because all these guys who
played
super played international so oh yeah
yeah yeah
and we had a hissing translator i think
that's the problem
when you have a treasure you don't even
want to learn japanese you know yeah
yeah and it was the same thing when i
went to
um to the international team as soon as
jamie said something now treasure was
just like
boom on on point yeah so it's kind of
like you're not really looking at jamie
just looking at the trays
yeah but like you know going into that
camp was uh i heard things about jamie
and then yeah
oh it's pretty intense i've never been
in a meeting what was that like just
sweating and
um no he just i remember the meeting
just telling us
what he wanted and what he expects
but you know he just needs to say a few
words and you know he's serious you know
no shrink it was good i remember getting
told off heaps of time mate
mate if you've got a jam jam if you
don't want to jam don't jam it's like
sorry i'm getting confused
um but yeah i learned the hardware i
remember getting the
opportunity to play i was in the camera
and i was ranking jazz i freak i don't
know if i want to do japan still
yeah and she's like i'll just write it
you know if you get opportunity get
opportunity if you don't
know you can say you've done it you know
so anyways played ireland
didn't play the first game against
romania but played the second game
against ireland
got lucky enough to to debut
and timmy was my partner you know 12 30
and then
timmy got injured um kept his run he
kicked it and
i think did his groin or something and
then yeah i partnered up with
um carpenter another great center yeah
derrick oh derek um yeah so we played
that um
and you know you get your review from
the coaches out of the game oh one was
hissing
loved it i never felt like quitting
footy like you know after you get those
reviews
oh right you you know you open it it's
like you don't want to open an email you
look at it like oh
you just see the first words he's angry
you know
i'm not going to open it so you used to
write a review
yeah you know the coach were like oh
look um they'll write a review of your
game
not one on one sit down no oh true write
it down just straight
look he's not even gonna see me so i'll
just say whatever i want to say
yeah i remember reading because i was on
hot so obviously uh
the test match finished and i didn't
play the last time i was suspended for a
spear tackle that i didn't think it was
a spear tackle
yeah um got on my holiday and then we
got the email you know
you know freak i wanted to enjoy my
holiday tour when i read that it just
i was like oh crap babe should i still
play or should i
should i just get back to us um but i
remember just getting looked back
everyone says you're a good tackler good
hitter love the contact
i saw none of that um mate
you need to really rethink about what
your strengths are and all those and so
yeah i guess mate look since you've got
the opportunity
hopefully you get opportunities on track
then tony gives me another
different one um he gives me a different
a different review you know look
i thought you tackled well thought you
did your job
uh the best thing
the best thing i took out of it jamie
just only wants the best
out of you i mean like what he says is
sunny day you just question yourself
like yeah maybe
i could do this better you know it's
never something to put you down
you know some players you're like
freakies but yeah
he's good i've built a really good
relationship over the years and you know
got to know him more and he got to know
me and um
yeah and yeah frick and you know tony's
saying this and james and i'm getting
confused like freak
was like good or was i bad right
yeah but you did mention it but you and
jamie did have a bit of a father-son
relationship didn't you
you're pretty close no he's just a good
bike
um i didn't have a father son i think we
just built a good respect for each other
um
got to know a bit more off the field he
got to know me a bit more
yeah i think he saw a bit of you
and himself am i right
what is it that he saw though
i'm not sure i remember you telling me
that after you
i think you're gonna you were gonna quit
um you're gonna quit uh
the japanese side and he set you down
and said i i
see you and me you're like a young
jamie joe no no he's he
made is an awesome guy she's probably
one of the
probably one of the best coach i've been
under you know
yeah especially with phila ttr yeah but
he's
i tell everybody you know when he's in
the building not like i've been to every
meeting with footy um like footy teens
but when he's in the room
the room's quiet they're like everyone's
got their books open their pens that
don't
a lot of them don't even drop down and
don't even use anything
especially the island boys that pretend
right something
um that's so funny man like the funny
thing i
get out of jay like who asks the boys
a question but he's already got an
answer right yeah
so you say something he's oh my what's
your thoughts about this and there's no
wrong answer you say something as you
look
i'm not saying the answer is wrong but i
think it's this would you agree on that
and you're like yeah i think
yeah oh good that's good we agree on
something you know it's kind of like
holy okay
um but uh freaking out you know
especially the island boy's a freak
he loves ripping into some of the boys
they and it's cracker because i see
myself
it used to be me when i first started
footy what were the japanese boys like
with him
nothing good they will respect way no
yeah real good
they they're real everyone's scared of
him obviously because
you know when he asks you a question you
need you need the answer he's looking
for but
no everyone got all right with him yeah
i feel like the japanese boys they
wouldn't be where they are without jamie
like yeah to push him you know to where
they are at the moment
um yeah and i mean what a world cup they
had so
let's go to the rugby world cup what a
what a tournament
home nation oh the whole country got
behind you
will turpo starting fullback first game
sold out what what a moment that must
have been unreal
until the first eyeball bat
[Laughter]
oh man i could talk you through that
freaking eyeball holy hell oh go on talk
me through it because
i know a lot of people ask like every
at the red sparks after that tournament
i remember
so much media and q and a's and
everything
the first thing he says about my my
introducing me is
my high ball my whole league
how about you just focus on running this
company
to victory no that's not nice anyways
uh the high ball anyways simple
we spoke about a simple plan what we
wanted to do
we wanted the exit right so obviously we
got the ball
i didn't exit and i was just i was
beating myself so you know you idiot
like why did you kick it out then you
know obviously he kicks it up
i'm still thinking about wide an exit
you know wall comes up
i see it and it just goes like literally
just going through my
yeah freak the easiest boarding
obviously they scored i didn't expect
the score of that but yeah frick yeah
crazy yeah
it's simple and then like you know
getting um
intermediate angles on it probably was
the light
just say if it's a light it's a lot you
know because they're thinking about
making changes you know
i don't know it wasn't a lot nothing
look i could say it was alive but it
wasn't a lot like i dropped it clean
you know and i said yeah as a fallback
you know you know
you need to they said maybe you're
nervous yeah to be honest i was quite
nervous
yeah but they're more angry that i
didn't exit and then you know
mixing those two together there's your
results drop ball
true how did you put that to the side
because you ended up having an awesome
game other than
the catch nah yeah i would just have an
awesome game but i was lucky enough to
still be on it i thought jamie's gonna
go yeah get him off right now
five minutes into the game
um no the boys like i said japan we had
a really good culture we we always
like when someone made a mistake it was
all like you know don't worry you know
if it was me what would you do we can't
hide that magenta like
would you keep going for me so you know
i remember you coming as
heads up tubes all good we got it we
kick off we did you know
get back on the field get back on track
and then you know obviously the boys are
scoring tries
but i'm still thinking about oh well i
just let them
score oh you were throughout the game
like the whole game i'm like holy hecker
like what the hell are you doing i'm
still thinking about i remember
there was another high ball i was trying
to tell you know nine played fullback
it's well my fitness is not the anyway
you know i'm trying to
run there and then i put my hands down
i'm not even there yet and it goes
it hits my hand i don't know how it
should have been a knock one or
something i don't know
and then i think lychee picks it up yeah
yeah
they must have felt sorry for me because
i dropped the first one so i let that go
but yeah like i was still thinking about
it then i remember jamie putting me
aside as mate look
i know you dropped the first four but
that's footy
it's world cup you're nervous you uh
jamie was real good man he was just he's
constantly talking to him
just get out there and just play your
game um
he'll always remind me of the good
things i did so it kind of like
it helps you get back on track yeah yeah
i feel like he's got a good
understanding of when guys are feeling
bad already not to sort of double down
on that but when when they're feeling
like reasonably good or
comfortable i guess that's when he'll
he'll go pretty hard on you
yeah no he was real good so obviously we
got the win
the boys played well to be honest
before the world cup i wanted to quit
like
yeah i i didn't want to do the world cup
like after i did the november test
i wanted to pull the plug because like i
got out of my sonny's contract and
obviously jamie told me mate look it's a
opportunity
that every player really wants to play
you know i thought of that
and i was like oh look one more um game
like you know one more comp with japan
wouldn't hurt you know it's a world cup
it's funny yeah so yeah so so why didn't
you want to play the world cup like what
was the reasoning behind
not wanting to play it i just had heaps
of um
like i just went through a lot of stuff
off-field
like uh i was saying now i
i suffered like bad depression and stuff
yeah and then
like that played a big role so that's
why i got out of my um
the sunny's one just to get on top of
that
and then um yes
and i didn't want to do the work i
didn't really care i just wanted to
focus on you know the contract that i
got
which was cola yeah then jamie um
he was pretty good in the way because i
was avoiding emails and he got a hold of
jazz's email
and jazz spoke to me look jamie's not um
he's not wrong you know maybe you can
just do this and then if you want to
continue with the international and then
you know
so obviously uh jamie told me to come
down to tokyo i flew down in tokyo we
were caught up for coffee and um
but it was it was pretty cool very very
safe you know i always tell the boys man
i thought
i thought the problem was me but hitting
the man brings his arm
like he sat me down and expected me he
showed me a picture of him being young
and how he moved home and when he got
married
like it was real cool man they're not of
that like he said look
we all go through it um i understand
what you're feeling in the situation you
you know
you come across um off field and stuff
and he told me look um have a think
about i'll give you time so he gave me
time
so they already started camp and he gave
me i think six weeks off with during the
camp
everyone's pretty peed off because you
know i've got the six week off and
they'll training
so jamie goes are you ready to come back
and i was like yeah look i'll come back
and he goes but if you don't if you
don't
think it's right for you after the week
you know then we can have another chat
and you can tell me like oh it's not for
me
yeah but yeah did that and enjoyed it
training was pretty cool
um getting vlogger i was getting a bit
chubby you know i didn't have to do
extras and stuff but i felt like it was
good for my mindset like
doing all these training uh starting to
enjoy footy a bit
um then jamie was like oh look so what
is the world cup
then let us know if you still want to
you know continue you know you to that
journey to
obviously being a potential player in
the world cup you know so
obviously did that still wasn't joining
a wolf pack then
went to fiji did or they did the pmc it
was lucky enough to get picked
in the pnc and then and i kind of went
you know what i'm in there already so i
might as well
try very hard to try to make the squad
so yeah
got picked well i can say the poc i wish
i did it properly because
obviously i was thinking about can't
wait to finish
yeah if that makes sense yeah like it's
amazing opportunity if you think about
it as a footy player it's the best
opportunity to show class
you know give it everything and now i'm
regretting like freak i wish i kind of
put aside my
the things i had off field and just
played
honestly running out in front of
everyone i was like it wasn't really
like holy
there's like who are you know all these
crowd it wasn't like that when i was
running out it was just kind of like a
normal game
and that's because i was thinking about
all these crap that was going through my
head
that's great yeah so is depression
something that you sort of suffered
throughout your career obviously you had
yeah heap of injuries and obviously
yeah 100 since i have to say i had to
said souls
yeah when i first started in a railway
yeah did you know it did you know what
it was no
i didn't know like i had friends who go
forward um
yeah i didn't know i had her until i saw
someone
two or three years ago i do i was i
didn't really believe in sitting with a
luck or what do you call them uh therapy
yeah therapy yes i did that right so i
did that and when i went back to brizzy
and then yeah the lady um
at that time was saying yeah this is not
good yeah this is probably something
that you kind of
uh grew up with um yeah
it didn't get real too but
obviously injuries are big family is a
big massive part
um expectations of others
yeah yeah and then they played a big
role that's why
when i talked to my friends like man why
would you give up the world cup and i
was like i'd really
to be honest i didn't really care about
making it or
being a part of the team you know like
but because
i was lucky enough to to have a good
coach to
talk me through it and like you know
don't throw something that you used to
love
you know or because of one thing so yeah
i took a born i took a border his when
he said to me his word of wisdom and
yeah right how good is that i i knew
that you were thinking about not doing
the world cup but i had no idea it was
what was going through your mind and you
were suffering with
a form of depression but man it's cool
that jamie joe was the one to be able to
sit you down and convince you to play
because
mate what a world cup you had and you
ended up becoming the whole face of the
nation for
for a while there and the whole japanese
public loved you
yeah fame's not something that i enjoy
but like yeah
it's i think for myself i think it's
very lucky to be able to able to have
the opportunity to play for japan
uh and being a world cup and beat
the face or japan obviously them doing
well but
you know i take it back to all the guys
who gave me this opportunity especially
jamie you know
if he didn't sit me down and talk talk
me through these hard times yeah i don't
think i would have had
would have gone for it yeah yeah so to
be honest he's
he's a great man and he understood what
i was gone through him
yeah like i said you know it's uh it's
something that i'll look back and go
look i'm glad i did the world cup and
was a part and played a role in the team
so yeah it's hard to explain hey
you're off you're right you're right on
fire anyway
what what's the plans what's the plans
from now you said that you're not going
to play japan anymore is that still
still the plan yeah i
i did say to myself like after the world
cup that will be my last
i didn't really tell anyone i was i
think jamie knew
where my head was i'm gonna focus on my
family and
whatever opportunity i get in japan um
if i if i do get that fire again you
know obviously you know i'll probably
try to put my hands up but you know
there's a lot of
good players coming up in japan so
probably too late i'll put my hands on
the goal
there's a lot of room to fill up bro but
nah
um yeah if it does come across obviously
you know that's something that i need to
think about but at the moment i just
want to
enjoy footy or try to enjoy footy
wherever i'm at um
yeah just to get that the fire burning
it's just at the moment it's just not
it's not happening
and you're off contract with the red
spark so hey
now i got i got the up i i signed a two
plus
pretty much like an optional bed pretty
much yeah everyone says it's a three
year deal
um so i've got to april next year but
apparently um
the budget's not looking great in cola
so
i think that's the new excuse for
something if you're not doing well
so the budget um
obviously we got told we can look
elsewhere
um oh true looking at my options and
back to the nrl you're kidding me could
you say that
no way imagine that a freak everything
is this guy i think he is yeah
japan come back
oh no yeah so life off
yeah don't know what i'm doing man to be
honest i
all that i know i'm still with kohler
i still wish we had the the same lads
at this team but like yeah like i said
you know
in this industry you can't choose what
you wanna you just gotta go with it
so when coke say that they they're
having budget cuts is that them saying
that they can't afford to pay you your
full contract that you've signed
um no the so what happens you know the
club said a club
obviously company you know how it works
so the company
the company gives us the budget right so
if they don't want to give us any money
that's why they say the budget so
they're going to know
because we've given you so much money
and you guys haven't really done
anything with that
well it's pretty hard wouldn't you win
owned by coaches but yeah anyways
um you know they say the budget and like
for my contract i saw in three years
they say the budget and they're saying
look um
so they're trying to change some stuff
in my contract and they said no we
didn't mean it that way
yeah so it's kind of like i'm at the
stage all if they want to
pay that money then i'm happy to give it
back
into their their budget then i can go
back on the market
but the thing is they won't release me
back on the market
oh yeah but the thing is i'm not going
to say if it's just
if it's only me imagine me just me being
taller by myself and not no foreigners
oh yeah you'd carry that america and
you'd care
mental health food's going to go up and
i might have to get freaking
freak i might have to do zoom claws
every day
well i'm here for you very i'm here for
you i'll
help you that shoulder you just you just
step away
i'm gonna have to bring you up and make
it can i do another podcast or
we can make it a weekly segment um what
about your plans after
rugby have you got oh got much it's a
joke
yeah because i've been telling myself i
want to quit i
you know i'm so i've got a good mate
that obviously gave me the opportunity
to come here i've spoken to him about my
plan
he sought off his company to obviously
try to
maybe try to keep get this um goal of
ours going
yeah it's more management i wanted to
i've never had any desire on any other
job but like i just spoke about
when i was stuck in this australia
during the covet i was i wouldn't i'm
going to visit my maid and told him i'm
very
do you think we'll go good if we're an
age like you know player agent because
what would you say don't say like if you
think about we've played a game we know
what it's
like to not get looked after and not get
told the right information
i would rather an agent go look man
they're looking for this guy you're not
in their plans
don't don't go on mate no they still
love you and then later on as you know
what they want to get rid of you're like
bro you could have told me that you know
so i can get around but
i just saw it um i wanted to help
players
like myself it's more like the honest
thing you know more respect your anchors
and i wanted to build a relationship
with a player not just
like have them make my bank account a
number yeah
yeah i don't want them just to feel i
don't want to have someone just to fill
up my backyard i wanted to have a
relationship
during their career and after we could
sit down and have a beer again mate what
a career you had
yeah now that you got a house family
whatever other thing and
i think that was the goal i wanted to do
and my mate loved it
sold his uh like a building company on
construction business he sold out
and now he's pretty much doing
everything for me while i'm still
playing so
he's caught up with his lawyers yeah
it's nothing big but like joe's like oh
do you know how to talk i was like well
this is the time to to try to go back to
the dictionary and find some long words
that i can use mate you'd be good at
that though because you're right
a lot of agents uh i mean a lot of
agents have
so many guys on there on their role that
they don't
really know who the hell you are at the
end of the day you're just another
another person i'm gonna say i'm gonna
say a agent
yeah i'm gonna say hey it's like one of
my i'll say my agent comes over
and i go to her oh cool um you go on to
panda she's yeah i don't know any of
them
i thought what do you mean she said i've
never met six of them
i was like i said can you tell me how
many clients you have in japan
she's yeah of course yeah i don't think
she's meant to be you know she's a
lovely lady so she tells you she's got
over 50 in this
this team to this team then when she
gets to the other side she's got
over 50. so it's like and i was like
sorry talk to do you
so what's the relationship with her do
you just know the big dogs and she goes
oh
i know majority of the so she's naming
all the big dogs so i should
i said what are these guys she says oh
um
wherever we can help them and you know
and i was like oh so
these guys get looked after first and
then she's no i'm not like that i said
well
pretty much yeah and then and then i
feel bad because
my agent calls me heaps and all the boys
like oh my have you heard from him but
i don't want to say yes look at oh here
he is that's kind of like
i think that's where i got the idea bro
because i just like yeah
but i don't want a big obviously for a
fern or
agency um company i just wanted
something to
yes it's something that i enjoy i reckon
i'll always enjoy having a good
relationship with people and um
tell them how it is you know because
that's gonna be very
rewarding too rewarding job seeing these
guys progress through their careers
knowing that you can help them
yeah well hopefully i might it's it's
just where the mouth at the moment
hopefully it happens have you got a name
or anything
because i mean so many footy players
listen to this probably looking for an
agent
they're like oh my he doesn't even have
a name no way
what a start
[Laughter]
what an awesome style all these ideas
and it doesn't have a name
um no i've got a few names bro about a
freak
jt agency
i'm gonna bring him up mate do you
reckon you could fund into my new um
company can you spend me a million bucks
freaking out my old jt man like yourself
mate play with you
freak learns a lot too
what what a journey in what a career but
before we go
mate we've got our instagram questions
okay first question best and worst lads
on a mad monday
interview do oh you would have had some
of the greatest
superstars in the world do i remember
those
um no they're all done
they're all they're good lads um there's
one stage we had to make money and um
i wouldn't say worse best and most lad
and jimmy and um
sergio had like a little
disagreement and who's jimmy
um james um tamu and they punched each
other
like so they knocked each other's teeth
and they went to the dentist in a couple
days just to fix
yeah said sorry each other i was like
what was that just so i don't know
they had a little argument and they
punched each other
cracked this took another one cracked
into one who does that
but who does that though yeah
oh that's the worst lad man what about
the best
i know who it is i'm just waiting for
you to say it
all right there's a lot of good lads man
i can't i can't answer that as heaps
he was like tell us one more jt story on
a mad monday because
you used to tell me these every day oh
you're such a
he's a good night he's a good man man he
goes might
give give them a pass my wallet around
to the lads let them grab their own
drinks and meals
[ __ ] no we're joking
[Laughter]
i was bringing coins out when i was
going out it was a whole league
hopefully the boys shouted me
man only had enough for the taxi there
and back
um willie tom was one of the best guys
on
oh yeah yeah always looked after me
um ray thompson yeah he's another good
kid that i looked after
um worse lads
that's a good answer i'm happy with that
okay
did jt's laugh ever annoy you
no i loved it
as you like hear it now it's like oh
true
that's what it sounds about like in the
moment i don't really
i've got an ugly life myself you know
but yeah
didn't know i didn't really annoy me it
was quite normal to be honest
yeah does that know you jimmy does that
youtube i'm a big fan man
i can't wait to get him on the podcast
but you'll hear heaps of laughing dude
you've got the hook up
anyway okay did you ever like rugby
yeah i think i love league more i'm not
gonna lie
yeah i i like drawing about i love
league
two different games but yeah union's
more of a thinking ama
you know what i mean like yeah like i
remember going to the foresight
league but yeah yes i'll leave now you
know i better
correct myself because all league of
legends what do you mean no but no
like union but
to be honest i miss like maybe because
i'm playing union at the moment but yeah
yeah i'll watch more league than i watch
union
fair enough okay this is this is on that
what did you find the hardest
about your transition from league to
union
yes it's a good question
um maybe passing
like because i was used to passing the
league style
like yeah then going to union trying to
i don't think i ever was a good passer
when i was playing anybody yeah trying
to
make that [ __ ] uh transition i'm kicking
because
in league the center's wing don't really
never
yeah never kick you know it's you either
run lines or you're a tackler
um that was the hardest maybe learning
how to kick but i knew how to kick but
not kicked the way
you look at all the centers and full
backs now kicking yeah like you know
i had to practice how to do that
defending
was massive in union you know you got
frontal back door
whatever an extra man comes around holy
heck league is pretty much you know you
stay on your own
yeah there was a lot of things um
working off the ball
yeah um and union you know i remember
running one board and just yell
done my job crushed it
oh yo i've done my job past it
someone's supportive anyway yeah just
day stuff um yeah to me it was quite
hard to be honest
i think once you've done both games you
understand
because you've done a leak like you know
you play league for a while and you
forget
where you sit in uni when you go back to
league
vice versa so yeah watch that so you
forget the little things that you
should be doing little details good
answer mate
real good okay this this is still on
that
people loving the league union stuff how
do you think tj will go
for the roosters
oh i reckon you'll go awesome
i reckon piranha in one thing lee
i mean hooker or um
five eight okay i think
i can go good is it it's quick off dummy
half like
as he is now he's smart um
he's a barker that's what you need from
a hooker directing your big picture
okay he'll kill it is it true that you
bench press 200
easy it's from rampage what a lad
oh well here he is wait i can't even i'm
still working on benching 100 bro
so if i did 200 i'll leave we'll be
partying for a week
no that's not true okay
this one have you got a story on jt
your favorite jt story this will be good
um a fair jt story
now i don't have a favorite one i have a
good supportive one i
remember having um
so anyways jazz was pregnant wasn't
william was uh we had a miscarriage
obviously
um and we had it we were flying out to
sydney
coaches were saying they understood my
situation but really they didn't
um jt told me mate you don't have to go
on this plane if you didn't so we were
waiting on the
before the boys were on the plane and he
was like came back to me
he told me what the situation was and i
said look the coaches wanted me to come
and kiss me it's up to you if you want
to come come and i said i'll come so
anyways
end up going and he spoke to the cage
for me
and i found out that we lost our little
one and he we got we did a beach walk
one morning and he like took me aside
and
spoke to me and like you know to have
something like that to you know to
acknowledge something like that it's
just like pretty cool yeah
you know to tell me like just go out
there tomorrow and
have fun and you know you um just make
sure you know all the boys are behind
you and stuff sure
yeah i remember kicking i was always
trying to pretend i was a kicker at uh
during training time and obviously you
know
kicked a lot of uh a little uh balls
that didn't go through and
kick somebody's mean why don't you even
try to kick another
i remember telling nah man that's not
for me you guys mate
you never know if you yeah you never
know if you have a crack of that and
i remember having a crack at 20s
sometimes and yeah
he said mate you should keep going but
i'm not a kicker i just found out i'm
not that kid come here just
just a number now he's a man bro i don't
know there's
there's a lot of good things i could say
about jt um
i don't know i like i remember he
organized every wednesday we have uh
hogs breath
all the labs get together the organized
data you try to build a culture
um i remember one stage we
i think we didn't get any money for our
man monday
because we started and man yeah
room i was like oh yeah the man slapped
some money on the tab and
had to put my coins back in my pocket i
was like yes
yeah man what what some money on the tab
when they
obviously we didn't get any uh money
from the club but yeah
no only good news bro he's the man right
yeah and you obviously learned a bit of
him because you were doing that at coke
um
last year you were the one paying those
bills
oh freak that's why we're just eating
lawson food from now on you know he's
like
money going no no way um
no no you know when you get under those
guys you know you learn
stuff from them and then you kind of now
because i'm a bit older
i'm a lot older now and so you know you
try to
learn from these experiences and then
use it may
that's for sure last but not
last question what's one piece of advice
you'd give a young kid coming through
the grades
uh one piece of advice thing but i like
one thing that i would say is never let
anyone tell you that you're not good
enough
or you can't do something it's it's
always
yeah keep working hard and never let
anyone tell you
you're not good enough for telling you
what you can't do you know
what a journey like i remember i live in
11 years ago
watching you you're my hero i had your
poster on the wall now i'm your mate
played with it mate what a journey it's
been
it's been such an awesome time getting
to know you
seeing you even you even bought a
computer to come on the podcast i mean
that's
that's next level commitment right but
really appreciate you coming on the
podcast giving up your time bro thanks
brother no i really appreciate it thanks
for having me
i really enjoyed watching your party and
i hopefully um
this one adds on um some good vibes eh
mate just some of the best vibes ever
and i haven't even talked about your
podcast yet but japan weekly you want to
give that one a shout out
one of the greats freaking out hey look
funny
man you're putting me on the spot i
don't even know what the podcast name is
for
japan weekly
japan weekly you and a few red spark
boys just talking a bit of
top legs outside of japan um
yeah hopefully there'll be more coming
up
we just need to um get some guests more
i think we need to interview you bro
like just sir let us know
what your thoughts of japan and red
sparks hey
anytime mate i'm i'm here man i'll be
happy to get you on
oh that'd be my dream always wanted to
get on japan weekly
love it favorite podcast
man you're a funny joker right man see i
missed yourself too
man you don't even know when you're
serious no anyways
yeah thanks man hopefully there's
parties um actually decent and i'm
i'm sure i didn't really answer the
questions but yeah
hey you're the man thanks for coming on
brother
thanks fella appreciate it man send it
out to the family take care bro
hey likewise bro
[Music]
[Music]
what
you